Persis sale process sale now I moved a
bit too far because I still need the
customers in you if a sale happens the
customer comes in wants to buy something
or hire something right yep what kind of
data are they going to get from a
customer and she may get some for what
kinds of things would you get this is
just when a purchase gets made and for
this another way do you think for this
process than just the sale okay do you
think a customer would have to provide
their name address and phone number
Pok says no why not
he's right folks right why wouldn't the
customer provide all that stuff that's
relevant right to the sale why wouldn't
they provide it Steve what eating
say it again privacy issues okay what
kind of privacy issues do you mean yeah
okay that's all right prep before price
issues will be relevant later on but I'm
going to suggest probably not a problem
because they already gave their details
in right so if they're worried about the
privacy of their name address and phone
number they probably wouldn't be she'll
be here or getting a membership never
what do you recommend go okay so you got
to think about this is data flow
diagrams it's not just okay here's
diagrams and there's the rest of the
topic it's elsewhere right one of the
important concepts on databases is
redundancy now if I've already got this
in my system it's already stored right
this is the whole point of having a
membership number this is kind of like
your this is your primary key once you
know that you've got all the rest okay
so probably the crucial piece of
eventually the customer parcels on is
the member number and they do that when
they swipe their card for another
practical reason apart from the fact
that there's redundancy okay can you
imagine how long a transaction would
take by how long the queue would be
every time you went up you're like okay
my name is this and my address is this
my phone oh but that would take forever
right that's kind of the point of being
able just swipe your card okay that's
probably not us not all that they are
provided right because in the question
it talked about the fact that you know
they don't make cash payments all the
time they can pay in other ways and it's
baked down here right yeah that's kind
of suspicious right so what other data
might they provide the customer at the
moment of sale
yeah okay credit card number or debit
card number or whatever I suppose we
could summarize all of that by see the
EFT details you remember what EFT stands
for the first three letters of F posh
with EFT yeah I think it's actually it
can be both but it's mainly funds
transfer right fun funds not not fun as
you like funds money okay so it's just
about money from one point to another so
whatever it may be it's a credit card
details or a Derick card or whatever it
is but those details are going to get
passed from the customer through this
process okay um that could be account
number in etc it all has to go you right
okay let's let's go along with that
right that kind of implies that the
bank's involved thanks involved okay so
some data is going you and some data is
coming back to the back what do you
reckon what kind of stuff are they
getting from them this is now from the
process let's say to the bank what are
they what are they sending to the bank
yeah okay good so again the same
electronic funds transfer details right
as before by the way you should watch
carefully if you can whenever your
parents are at the shops if they pay by
credit they pay by card right the F post
machine little terminal sometimes its
handheld sometimes it's actually you
know it's bolted to the register right
but if you watch it you'll see actually
do this process right it'll say dialing
and then it'll say requesting and it'll
say processing and so on okay
every single time is kind of like a
little phone call that happens and
there's a little process it happens
between them and probably not
necessarily the bank directly might be
the host merchant that comfy but
eventually it's going to get to the bank
right in this transaction is to take
place all right
if that's what they sent what's the bank
gonna send back or what's the host gonna
send back yeah that's right
confirmation maybe not even confirmation
because confirmation says yeah it's done
right what if my cards burgers or I've
hit my credit limit what are they going
to said because they're not going to
confirm something that
not not and that didn't actually go
through right there's a step before
confirmation which is whether it gets
approved or not
okay so they'll send approval or lack
thereof okay
right now so far we've got the customer
actually coming in buying some stuff and
the this is the the funds transfer part
of it but I assume it's going to be
connected to the rest of the store right
so in what ways will be connected can
anyone give me some suggestions what
kinds of things for instance might be
going into that central database is a
young this is a DVD store and they're
borrowing stuff what kinds of things are
they going to turn I live okay so you
know we've got one des of this DVD on
offer now okay or two or ten or whatever
right and that has to get updated good
and what are the kinds of things because
remember I saw yeah good glue okay so
not just stock details which is that
what we have in store but I suppose are
yellow in details would be a very good
way of saying I've run out of space
because the store was the keep track of
who's got their stuff and when it's due
right and that's all to do with the load
good pickup okay now probably this video
start store database is going to pass
through to fish it back right what else
might it put back back to the snare
yeah good so overdue notices right or
maybe it will just pass back information
about but not necessarily overdue but
just whatever is still on that person
that members card okay so more member
details all this happens in one
transaction okay oops okay what else we
got here now I think in the case of the
sale right this time some data is going
to come from the sales staff and not
from the customer okay because we sort
of assumed like what if they come up
there customers come up and they've got
well the member card right that's going
to be let's get some random let's see
yeah [ __ ] juice no okay so something a
mission card of some kind right let's go
to memory card swipe right then you've
got the payment okay so you know turn it
turn it this way so you can't see my
actual number okay is my credit card but
there it is
swipe okay so that's done but what else
is the customer brought with them if
they're going to borrow some stuff from
this store it's not just these two cards
right what are they got the actual video
right I'm gonna swipe in and pay you but
just for the heck of it cuz winner so
they're actually going to bring you know
whatever it is that they're actually
borrowing right and there's some data on
here that's relevant to the sale right
what data is relevant the barcode thank
you that can't come from the customer
right I think that's probably really
going to come from the sales stuff
because the other one is actually making
the process happen so I suppose we were
saying here on video barcode for DVD
Marco
okay now precious sale that was a pretty
complicated process right there was a
lot of data flowing in and out from a
lot of different groups of people and a
lot of different sources with
destinations okay now we're on to our
last one over here move your returns do
you reckon you could do it without me
helping you where area's going to go
what do you think sales staff to or
fraud to why and what stuff will be
provided
okay put yourself in the position you
are you're the sales staff right and
it's the start of the day right so you
go you walk over to the I assume there's
like some kind of bin at the front of
the store where there's like a chute
that goes into it overnight a whole
bunch of people have walked up and put
in all of these returns okay so you go
you pick it up and then what do you do
you take one up and you're scared what
are you scared you're scanning the scene
barcode that went out right so that you
know okay this one is returned right so
the same way a barcode is going to get
scanned and so that we know okay good
this one I can check it off I can take
that's returned I can update some stuff
details and so on how am I going to do
that where's this purchase going to send
and receive data from yeah that's right
it's going to send some data here right
so I'd probably say things like the
return date all the time okay other
things like the barcode number which
you've got from the sales staff right
it's got a check to see who does that
model to which member does it um is it
currently registered to write and
that'll all go in now does any data come
back from anyone like this does this
does this come back to here and send
stuff back to that process you possibly
could have a yep I checked it out like
that's okay it belongs right possibly
but it's sort of like a it's a very very
small amount of data and it's sort of
trivial to the system right you can
imagine system where no data is returned
because like well I don't really mind I
don't the job of this process is to
update this not vice versa
okay later on this is going to provide
something fresh to the reports and
they'll be able to see oh yeah I all of
these were came in these came out these
ones are latent someone but that'll
happen later not as a perp as a part of
this process okay
all right now there you go from memory
something done too badly but I think
people were a bit sloppy as they went
through and and put a lot more
connections than are sorry there are two
kinds of errors you put too many
connections you're like yeah the
customers talked to you know there's
like yeah we're gone over here we're
doing this and we're you know we're
talking to the bait cuz why not and or
and you're all you know for example
directly interacting with the database
which is a big no-no okay all you had to
a few maybe I don't know you just like
all doing one of these again I had bad
memories and then you never came back to
it because you know it was super long
okay but that's generally what you're
looking at remember the process I went
through get it I was looking at the
processes and going through them one by
one
okay they're kind of like Mikey and I
just think about what data they're going
to get and who are they going to get it
from that's it okay